Here's our coding solution
for the share action provider.
let's start by adding a string.
The string will be used
for the label for our action.
Now we're going to add
a new menu resource.
This resource will be
for the detail fragment.
We'll start by adding the name space used
by the Android support library
for its widget XML.
Finally, we add the actual item.
This menu item contains
the string that we just added
from the strings file.
It's always shown as an action,
so it appears on the action bar.
And its actionProviderClass
is the ShareActionProvider
from the Android support library.
The Android support library
allows the ShareActionProvider
to be used on earlier versions
of Android, then 4.0,
when it was officially added
to the framework.
Next, let's go to the DetailActivity.
We're going to be looking
at the DetailFragment
within the DetailActivity.
So the first thing we can do
in our fragment is
to add a few useful things.
Let's add a log tag,
a string for the share hashtag,
#SunshineApp,
and we're going to take
the forecast string
and make it a member variable.
Next, in onCreate view, let's actually
populate our member variable.
And then finally, use it to set the text.
let's create a share intent.
This intent uses ACTION_SEND.
This FLAG_ACTIVITY_CLEARED_
WHEN_TASK_RESET is somewhat important.
It prevents the activity
we're sharing to from being
placed onto the activity stack.
What will happen,
if we don't have this flag,
is when you click on the icon
to return to the application later,
you may actually end up
in another application,
the one that's actually
handling the share intent.
When FLAG_ACTIVITY_CLEAR_WHEN_TASK RESET
is used, it'll actually return you
to your application instead.
We've set the type, test/plain,
to let Android know we're going
to be sharing plain text.
And then we share
our forecast string, plus our hashtag.
Only one more thing left to do.
We have to add the menu
to the fragment.
To do this, we have to set
a flag that this fragment
has an options menu at all.
Otherwise, it won't actually call
the onCreate options menu member function.
Finally, here's our onCreate
options member function.
As you can see, we're inflating
the detailfragment menu
that we created earlier.
Finding the share item,
getting the ShareActionProvider,
and attaching our intent
to this ShareActionProvider.
You'll want to update this
whenever the data
you want to share changes.
And that's it.
You've now added
a ShareActionProvider into Sunshine.